Any advice for a grieving parent
who lost a child unexpectedly?
Well,
one I would say make sure that you turn
to the people that you have left that
you love.
The second I would say is
don't be guilty about grieving.
You know,
and if you have friends,
you can tell them,
you could let them do something nice
for you because they would like that you
can figure out something they
could do that would be nice,
that you would appreciate
and let them do it.
Because you know,
other people are going to grieve
at some point in the future too.
And maybe they'll be able to
ask you for help if you do that.
And then,
well,
I would,
the next thing I would
say is give yourself time.
You know,
it takes a year,
maybe longer to adapt,
to adjust even reasonably
to such a catastrophic loss.
And then I would say try not to allow
that terrible wound to make you bitter
because then not only will you
have lost your child and grieve,
but you'll be bitter and then you'll be
resentful and then you'll be hateful.
And that'll be like a terrible,
that'll add insult to injury,
so that's too bad.